hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Renea take hearts arguments for the
existence of God and his discussions of
the nature of God are just as important
for the entire Cartesian project as is
the more famous Koji to--they I think
therefore I am lying an insight that he
has why is this well he's going to use
the nature of God and the existence of
God as a linchpin in the entire rest of
his argument in fact in both the
discourse and the meditations that's the
next thing that he's going to discuss
after he explores the the nature of the
human being as a thinking thing and why
does he do that because he needs the
idea of God as a perfect being a being
possessed of all perfections in order to
get the rest of his project off the
ground so it's very important when we're
looking at the discourse to examine the
two arguments that Descartes provides
and to look at the nature of these
different attributes or qualities or as
he's going to call them perfections now
he provides two distinct arguments and
one thing that you can say about both of
the arguments is that they work on the
basis of considering our ideas so one of
them is labeled explicitly as an
ontological argument not the term that
decart himself uses that is a later term
and it's similar to earlier versions of
that as you can find them in in Anselm
and Thomas Aquinas put forth by an some
rejected by Thomas Aquinas the other one
has to do with an idea as well and both
of them work by not looking at the world
as such but looking within our minds and
considering the very nature of those
ideas so let's start with the first one
because that's the one he brings up
before the other one and you could say
he's doing this
the absence of any other proof whereas
the ontological one he's bringing this
up as sort of a secondary proof so let's
let's follow through how this works I've
put the bare bones of it here but we
have an entire passage in which he goes
through it so let's pay attention to the
text so he says that he wanted to look
for the source from which he'd learned
to think of something more perfect than
himself he he knows that he is lacking
certain perfections if he didn't lack
perfections then for example he wouldn't
be in doubt because to doubt to waver
between ideas or to not be able to
commit to them entirely is an
imperfection a lack of being perfected
and we should probably pause for a
moment when Dickert is using this term
perfection we often tend to think of it
in terms of you know an external
criteria that we impose there's an
earlier notion of this that comes from
ancient philosophy where the perfection
of something is reaching the highest
point of its development and there were
indeed a lot of arguments where you know
perfection sort of goes downward and
Descartes is relying on something rather
similar to that so he's asking this
question all right I've got an idea
of something more perfect than myself
because as soon as I start you know
hearing that phrase or thinking about it
I've got that idea in my mind where did
that come from
did I get that the way I have with say
my idea of light or solid substance from
sense perception I wouldn't get anything
like that from I you know ideas derived
from the world he says those aren't
really that big of a problem I you know
maybe those are illusory maybe you know
they actually do refer to something
outside of myself we're not going to
worry about that right now where did
this idea of something higher than
myself come from a perfect being he says
they can't come from myself why not well
if if I could produce this own idea
within myself then I would actually know
what it is to be perfect I would just
make myself perfect right and then it
would be kind of a moot point so it's
not coming from me says it's manifestly
impossible that that you know it could
come from myself and then it also can't
come from nothing you can't get anything
from nothing and the word that he uses
here is neots non-being
the idea of perfection has to come from
something from somewhere so he says it's
no less contradictory than that the more
perfect should proceed from and depend
on the less perfect than that something
should proceed from nothing so where
could this idea be coming from he goes
on he says there remains only one
possibility this idea had been put
within me and planted within my mind as
he says by a nature which was truly more
perfect than mine now you could say at
that point if he had only said that
maybe it comes from a being that's more
perfect than me but not completely
perfect so Descartes goes on here and he
clinches this argument by saying that he
says one which even had in itself all
the perfections of which I could have
any idea so if we're thinking about
perfection and this is this is a it for
us a continual process we don't
automatically have the idea fully
fledged fully spelled out of what a
perfect being would have that's going to
have these these attributes that we'll
talk about in just a moment
as we do this as we think about what
these attributes would be we realize
according to Descartes that this idea is
indeed of something like a god and where
could that idea have come from we've
already eliminated the other
possibilities it must have come from God
now could it have come from God if God
didn't exist no therefore God exists
so this is one argument and notice that
again no appeal to the outside world you
might say well there therefore it is an
ontological argument
it depends on how you define ontological
arguments strictly speaking this is not
an ontological argument it's an argument
about a certain kind of causality so in
a way it's similar to cosmological
arguments if we're talking about you
know the philosophy of religion but
cosmological arguments talk about the
cosmos the universe and causality
operating here we're looking at
causality operating within the realm of
our ideas so that's the first argument
the second argument is definitely an
ontological argument that is it's an
argument that proceeds just on the basis
of the idea of God and then unpacked
something about that idea that says that
existence must necessarily belong to
whatever that that thing is that that
that the idea corresponds to here
Descartes gives you might say less of a
proof one of the things that's going on
here is an assumption that you're
actually looking at these ideas so he
says if I look at for example a triangle
he says I called to mind the object of
study of geometers he talks a little bit
about space and stuff like that and then
he says I observed that the great
certainty which everybody attributes to
geometry is based only on the fact that
these proofs are conceived of as
incontrovertible as not being able to be
refuted so let's think about triangles
for a moment he says if a triangle
exists you can prove that it necessarily
has 180 degrees between the three angles
the way that it's a
here it's three angles were equal to two
right angles so you know two 90s 180
degrees now of course you could object
well what about non-nuclear in geometry
okay well that wasn't in decart's mind
at the time and I'm sure he would have
other things that he could bring up you
know
similarly dealing with geometry and
hypotheticals and he says now this
doesn't get you that far because maybe
there's no triangles in existence all we
know is that if a triangle exists then
it necessarily has these properties
right but it doesn't tell you that a
triangle actually does exist in reality
so what about God Descartes says if you
consider the idea of God or of a perfect
being then you realize that among those
perfections is existence it is less
perfect to not exist than it is to exist
or to if you prefer to have being than
not to have being so therefore as soon
as you consider the idea of God and
you're actually thinking it through you
must realize that different from the
triangle which might not exist God or
this perfect being necessarily exists
there is no option there is no
alternative to this so a perfect being
must exist in reality this is rather
similar to Anselm's argument in in how
it's constructed it's working off of
somewhat different ideas but it is an
ontological argument in that respect and
we're not going to go into criticism of
those here there's plenty of discussions
of that instead let's talk about what
Dick Hart gets out of this so we've got
God existing through one of two proofs
what is God what is a perfect being so
Descartes tells us about a number of
different interesting quality
and he says listen if you want to know
what a perfect being is just think about
what it is to be perfect what what are
the different qualities that go into
being perfect and you can do this in a
positive way you can also do it in a
negative way you can look at yourself
and say well you're definitely not
perfect
how are you imperfect what would it be
better for you to be like so for example
he says that God does not doubt right I
doubt it because I don't know things and
that would go sort of to the omniscience
thing if I knew everything I wouldn't
doubt so he says you know there's
there's no doubt there's no inconstancy
there's no sadness and such things in
god-given that I would be glad to be
free of them he also tells us a few
other things so the the ones that he
brings up at the start are infinite God
is not limited that's what infinite
means right
eternal God exists throughout all time
perhaps even surpassing time depending
on how you conceive of time there is no
time you could say in which the perfect
being does not exist unchanging to
experience passions like sadness or
things like that would be a change
there's other ways in which God is going
to be unchanging as well
omniscient well you know if you if you
were to lack any knowledge then you
wouldn't be perfect like the heart says
I lack knowledge that's why I doubt
therefore I know I'm not perfect he
brings up a existence of course in in
the the proof and he also brings up
simplicity and here he has a very
important set of remarks he says I had
ideas of many corporeal things in the
realm of the sensory even if I were to
suppose I was dreaming and everything I
saw it was false I could not deny the
ideas were really in my thought right I
recognized that in my own case the
nature of the intellect is distinct from
the nature of the body and considering
all composition is evidence of
dependence and that dependence is ad
the opposite of perfection I concluded
that God could not be a composite thing
God can only be one thing this is what
it means to be perfectly simple God
doesn't have a mind and a body the way
that that we do what about goodness this
is going to be very important because
the curt will use the perfect goodness
of God to argue that we can rely upon
not necessarily all of our sensory
experience but we can rely upon an
important principle that everything that
we perceive clearly and distinctly is in
fact true why because God would not set
things up both within the world and
within us in such a way as to deceive us
now why wouldn't God do that why
couldn't God say be testing us or
messing around with us because that
would contradict the very nature of a
perfect being we would do that sort of
thing
but that's a sign of how screwed up we
are God doesn't do that sort of thing
therefore we're going to be able to rely
not only on the veracity of God but also
on that key principle of clear and
distinct ideas and that there is some
sort of order for us to find in the
physical universe so Descartes is really
drawing a lot more than just the
argument that well God exists so except
that there's a God he's using this as a
key part of his entire master project
you